[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Rick is
in Boston hi Rick welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up well 65 years old um and
wondering if I'll be able to retire at
72 and be okay with my current
situation okay what's your current
situation okay well um I'm I'm very
healthy and very well in shape I have a
great job I plan on continuing to work
um I still owe 136,000 on my home I
would like to have that paid off by the
time I do my retirement at
72 um I have a truck um 30,000 on the
truck and um in March of this year I
installed solar on my my roof um I'm not
sorry I did that uh that was a
$22,000 I bought it out right $22,000
loan UMR is it a loan or did you buy
it uh well it's it's through a uh um I
took out a solar loan so it's a loan
okay so you're $22,000 in debt on solar
what else correct uh 18 left on that by
the way um trying to pay trying to pay
that off I have not yet received my
federal uh percentage my T for taxes
next year but that's going on on there
so that'll be down to like nine grand
probably in March of next year um I have
401K I have 5,000
emergency and I have zero credit card
debt I do
alamon uh 100 Grand a year okay I pay
alimon
approximately just about 10,000 a year I
have till November of 24 okay what I
would do if I were in your shoes is I
would get these two debts paid off
immediately and I would stop I would
stop adding to your 401k temporarily and
I want you uh I want the truck and the
solar paid off inside of 12
months really beans and rice rice and
beans you have no life until you get
that done that is that is job one it's
an emergency or sell the stupid truck
one of the two well I can't that's you
know my only vehicle well you could get
another vehicle you a $30,000 one but uh
yes you can well actually it's a $60,000
truck I only owe 30 grand on it I had oh
good then you could sell it and get a
$30,000 car okay yeah I'd sell it right
now buy a $10,000 car and pay that other
debt off too yeah yeah yeah yeah because
you don't have any money yeah well
you're 65 years old and you're
broke yeah um so here here's I had a
plan let me let me tell you what my plan
was you tell me if you think this is
work if this is good or not and I
totally listen to you guys um in in 14
in 14 months um my alimony payment stop
so that's another 10 grand that I have
that I was thinking about um putting
back into my 401k and trying to catch up
um I'm also going to be hit my full
retirement age so I can start taking my
Social Security which is about $3200 a
month and I was going to try and pay off
the loans with that the house the truck
well the solar by then but the solar I'm
not really worried about because I've
been making a lot of payments on that
and that'll be just about gone um but
between the house and the truck I with
my you know in continued to work um I
thought maybe because you know what do
you figure 30 3200 a month in um Social
Security yeah you're about 500 or
$600,000
behind yeah I know yeah and so um no I
think your plan's too slow I would get
get more radical if I was in your shoes
I would get a $330,000 truck I would
sell this one or or a $10,000 truck and
I pay off the stuff by Christmas I'd be
debt free other than the house uh and
every dollar I can squeeze out I'm I'm
then going to start putting 15% of my
income into retirement and everything
else towards this house and I want the
house paid off in like three
years not in seven years and then I want
you to just loading up 401ks and Roth
IRAs and anything else you can load up
in good mutual funds then you will end
up with about $400 or $500,000 and a
paid for house at 72 the track you're on
right now you're going to end up with
about $250,000 in a paid for house at
72 and that that there's about a
$250,000 swing in what you're planning
to do and what I'm teaching you but I'm
teaching you some sacrifice you don't
really want to do and you got to quit
saying crap like the cellular was a good
idea it wasn't a good idea broke people
don't spend $22,000 on cellular solar
solar whatever it is yeah and you got to
qu money don't buy cellular either you
got to quit you got to quit buying money
borrowing money you don't have any you
don't have any money that's my point you
got to stop this you can't you can't
talk about this is this is okay this is
okay this it's not okay it's killed you
man I mean you make good money and you
got virtually no money so um I mean I'm
not saying you're horrible but you're a
c minus student at this this is not an
A+ you're not you didn't flunk you're
not you're not retiring it with Social
Security only that's flunking right but
but uh but you know you you got to lean
into this and yeah I'm with John if I
woke up in your shoes what would I do
I'm about your age I mean I'm 63 so if I
woke up in your shoes I'd be driving a
$10,000 truck I'd be debt free and I'd
have a game plan knock that 136 out so
fast it's unbelievable meanwhile dumping
everything else I can find into my 401k
getting you know Roth IRAs and load
those puppies up because here's the
thing seven years it'll double whatever
you're doing whatever you got in your
lump some today it'll double if if it's
in good mutual funds so that 110 that's
there will be two will be 220 and your
house will be paid for that's your
250,000 I'm talking about that's what
you'll have uh you might have a little
bit more than that if you if you get
aggressive on putting some in you might
have 300 but you could you could have
600 and we talked and then you can buy a
truck we talked about this earlier the
confrontation will come and this
confrontation is going to be be between
you and math it's coming you can you can
manage it on your terms right now and
make some sacrifices some pretty hard
sacrifices or you can just wait and it
will hit you at 88 and you're ward of
the state yep